hi good afternoon
i'm mohammad kasimi and i'm an assistant
professor of computer science michigan
state university
and a national scholar for data and
technology advancements at the national
institutes of health this year
i'm joined today by my colleagues at the
nih dr grace peng doctors jim nott
christina fang and
susan wright
and uh today we
have had a slight technical issue which
is going to
change some of the format today we will
we will not be having a debate because
uh some technical challenges but we will
instead
be performing an interview of professor
david kleinfeld
who i am going to introduce momentarily
before i
kick off the interview
i would like to
emphasize two points
the first point is that in the course of
this debate
professor kleinfeld has very generously
offered to cover the the two sides sort
of the arguments for and against our
debate question
which is can we generate an organized
theory of the brain
so i want to really thank professor
kleinfeld for for agreeing to sort of
help us understand the nuances in the
fore as well as the against side of that
discussion the second thing i'd like to
bring up here at the start is that
we're very interested in hearing from
members of the audience with your
thoughts reactions and follow-up
questions so please go ahead and post
those in the questions window and we'll
sort of pass those those along uh when
the
interview period
concludes and we enter the q a period at
the half hour mark
okay so with that purpose out of the way
i'd like to briefly motivate
the topic for today's interview
the human brain is a mysterious organ
that translates electrochemical impulses
neurons into thoughts feelings and
behaviors and so there's some
hope that if we could organize and
understand the activity of the human
brain we might be able to harness that
knowledge
to treat brain disorders such as
alzheimer's or brain abnormalities like
autism or maybe we could even get some
insight into great unanswered questions
of science like what is consciousness
and
if you listen to some of the talks
earlier today
you've probably seen that
neuroscientists are making great
progress towards
unraveling some of the mysteries of the
brain but we still are not
or don't have in our our clutches a
single unified organized understanding
of how the brain works that's akin to
for instance our understanding of how
transistors work together to enable your
laptop
um so this is sort of an overview of the
motivation
of motivating questions for the debate
which is can we generalize
or generate an organized theory of the
brain
now having said that i'd like to very
quickly introduce
our distinguished
speaker today
yes
muhammad i think florian is actually on
the phone oh wonderful okay
so there will okay that's great so what
we're going to do is we're going to come
back to instead of structuring this as
an interview we're going to we're going
to kick it back then to
the original debate format so i will uh
introduce both of our distinguished
speakers and i want to note here up
front that i could occupy this entire
session reading off their many
accomplishments but given that we had a
little bit of a delay i'm gonna give you
the the abridged version of their
background
so representing the
four camp for the purpose of the
discussion today is professor david
kleinfeld he's a distinguished professor
at uc san diego where he leads a diverse
multi-disciplinary laboratory that
focuses on issues and systems
neuroscience he's a member of the
american academy of arts and sciences
and a fellow at the american association
for the advancement of science at
science uh dr kleinfeld thank you for
joining us
and we also are going on the line today
by
on who is representing the against
uh camp is professor florian ingert
he's a professor at harvard university
where he leads a laboratory studying
neuroethology and the evolution of
adaptive natural behaviors
he's recipients of several awards
including awards from the mcknight
foundation the nih director's pioneer
award program and the human frontier
science program
uh dr anger thank you so much for
joining us
it's a pleasure
welcome and thank you for having me
absolutely so okay uh having said that
we've i've given you an abridged version
of these two uh giants backgrounds i'm
not going to be able to mention all the
other wonderful accomplishments they
have so let's just jump into the debate
now
we're going to begin with some opening
statements from each side
i think five or so minutes is what you
could aim for but you can go a little
more a little less as it works for you
and then we will pose additional
questions thereafter so let's start with
um let's start with the four camp dr
kleinfeld i'd love to hear your thoughts
on what evidence is there to suggest
that we might one day be able to
generate an organized theory of the
brain
um okay i mean some of this of course is
based on
hope but you might say i i started out
in physics and you only go into physics
if you have a certain hope that um
you'll have a somewhat simplified
description of the world
but
my feeling is this uh we have a pretty
good understanding
of dynamical systems both at the
low level which means we could write
down fairly exact so-called
conductance-based equations
for single cells or
groups of single cells
put in a lot of what we know about the
kinetics and thermodynamics of channels
and and get a a very good uh model
representation
of what we see and and maybe more
importantly we even have a lot of
knowledge about how to abstract this and
we also have a good knowledge of
dynamical systems at the very large
level at the population level it doesn't
mean we're averaging
out um
all the all the uh details of when
different neurons are active but it
allows us again to have a somewhat
simplified uh view a conceptual
understanding of what's going on
and and there's been great strides i
mean everybody has their favorite
experiment
my favorite experiment is the the ring
of tractor that uh
vivek jayamon identified in the fly that
hayan some polinsky worked on
theoretically in terms of a stat neck
model
but it's
it's it's it's a great achievement um
but on the other hand it's really a
one-dimensional system
and i think what's missing is there's a
serious uh experimental understanding
of the dynamics of systems where the
same elements
uh which are imposing the dynamics
synapses
uh samada are also storing information
and being continually modified and this
is quite different than the situation
uh we have an electronics and if you
we
we know a fair amount about synapses on
the one hand uh we know about things
like spike timing dependent plasticity
uh so the work from starting with curtis
bell and then mooming-poo
but we really know very very little
about plasticity it seems to be the one
area that's neglected john nye was
talking this morning about the cell
census and all the details about neurons
and their development and maybe how
they're hooked up together but we we
don't understand
uh we don't have experimental clues to
allow us
to develop a theory
which includes plasticity at the
connection between neurons and to some
extent in the expression of threshold
levels of neurons themselves
so i'm i'm optimistic but i think
there's a big hole in our gap and
there's a dearth of experimental
evidence and um i must say i'm just
thought the um
you know sort of the excuse of this
debate with uh
my friend florian
is a good point to represent this this
hole in our knowledge because it's also
i think the kind of program
that the brain effort should go after it
should go after fundamental holes in our
knowledge
okay so that's
that's you may that you may say is my
treatise optimistic but we need some
strong experimental clues to understand
the distributed uh memory and plasticity
within the nervous system
awesome thank you so much for your
opening statement dr kleinfeld let's
continue now with an opening statement
from
uh dr enger
who has kindly agreed to sort of serve
in the against camp i want to emphasize
again here that all scientists i think
hold nuanced views on complex questions
so
it would be unfair to say that either dr
kleinfeld or dr anger are strongly
representative of either a for or
against camp but for the purposes of
educating us in the debate today they're
they're agreeing to sort of highlight
the different sides of the issues so
having said that i dr engert i'd love to
hear your thoughts on what is the
evidence uh that suggests that we may
not be able to generate an organized
theory of the brain
yeah so yeah the question is an
organized theory of the brain
and um i'm still struggling with what
exactly the question is or what would
constitute
when would we know that we actually have
a theory now that we didn't have before
so i think
at the heart of everything here is the
question of what constitutes
understanding and when we actually
think we have
managed to slate from ignorance to
understanding and then i had a a
wonderful discussion preemptively for um
this meeting today with david kleinfeld
two days ago when he um called me um
when i was hanging out in a mountain hut
in the dolomites now i'm
at the at the ocean side campground in
um
in italy so i apologize for the for the
telephone and i hope my my connection
will hold anyway i i think the um two
examples that david brought up two days
ago where we did not have um a theory
and then we had it and we knew one was
understanding atoms
atoms and we needed quantum theory to
understand them and i think that's an
excellent example
where a theory was missing and then we
had it and then we
could move forward and i think the other
one was magnetism where um coulomb
forces like the
repulsion of um
of charges was not sufficient to explain
um
magnetism and i think ultimately we
needed um special relativity
to uh as a theory to explain magnetism i
think the two excellent examples maybe a
somewhat
more stretched one is the theory of
evolution that explains the
diversification of species and i think
at that level
i'm not sure we are lacking a theory i
think
there's everything we need to understand
neural networks and dynamical systems
these fundamental principles are already
in place
i don't think we even need um quantum
mechanics to explain um
the brain or neurons i also don't think
we actually need magnetism of course all
of this depends on what you mean by
understanding and how deep you have to
go so um i think our current
misunderstand or a lack of understanding
of how the brain works is really based
on synapses and neurons and the
interplay between them
so my hope is that the current
principles we know about neuroscience
mainly about how neurons work in
principles principle and how synapses
work in principle
is sufficient to explain the
computations that all brains perform in
order to solve the solutions that
animals can control and to survive and
to to be adaptive
um so having said that maybe another
analogy is are we also lacking a theory
about the heart or the kidney yes sir
because i mean some people say that
we have theories um or we have an
understanding of how um
electronics or man-made objects work
like like computers and transistor
radios and um
but we we lack an understanding of
biology because biology is just much
more complicated and
and and harder to understand because we
haven't built it i agree with that i
think understanding how a cell works is
um is still beyond us currently a single
cell um but i don't think it's for the
lack of a theory i think it's um for the
lack of putting together
all the little bits and pieces starting
with biochemistry with physics with um
all the mechanisms the biological
mechanisms that um explain how cells
work at the cellular at the molecular
level how biochemistry works i think if
you put all of this together then
understanding of how the brain works
will slowly emerge and it's not the lack
of a cohesive theory it's really um the
lack of putting all the individual bits
and pieces together and i think slowly
in the next
decades
um
an understanding of the brain as a
complex dynamical system will start to
slowly emerge without a fundamental
paradigm shift
that
that we are all waiting for that's
currently under debate i want to finish
my um
my my initial statement with a poll that
maybe you can conduct
amongst all the audience
and i would like to ask them and if you
give them a choice between a and b
yes so fourth choice they have to um
choose either a or b
and a is we are still lacking a
fundamental understanding a theoretical
understanding and once we have
discovered how this works
and we will have an inside a eureka
moment and we can move on so that's
option a
and option b is that it's we have all
the principles in place and it's just a
question of incrementally and advancing
it then i would like to know what the um
the audience and how they would vote
right and do they think there is some
fundamental mystery or some some theory
still and lacking and once we and have
found it we will know and we can move
onward at a at a at a different level or
is it just um as i previously suggested
baby steps i don't know whether it's
possible to do this quickly with an
audience like that but i do this um
frequently when i have an audience at my
disposal and um it's actually
fascinating um what the responses are
it's usually 50 50 and the um
the uh
answers are diverse and and very
interesting anyway that's what i have to
say um as an opening statement and i'll
i'll hand over the
mic back to
mohamed david's
thank you so much professor anger for
the opening statement so one thing that
i i heard echoed by both of you was
i bring my own bias as a as a computer
scientist to wanting to draw an analogy
between the brain and obviously moving
from a you know a transistor system all
the way up to
a computer that has an operating system
that's close to the top of it all these
layers of abstraction that we can
understand how each of those work
together to inform the other
and i heard from both of you in the
course of your opening statements that
that analogy has uh has flawed
what i was uh what i was hoping that we
could do is expand maybe on each of your
perspectives or from each of your
perspectives on if there is a good
analogy to think about or if the system
is
is is unanalogous there's not a good
sort of parallel for people to think
about when they want to understand
what a unified theory would look like
because in the computational sense
um you know we think if we can
understand from the transistor all the
way up to the os then we've got it all
pinned down what what is the right way
for us to be thinking about this when
we want to speak about an organized
theory of the brain if if the
transistor sort of analogy is not the
right one maybe we can start with
professor yes mine failed and then we
can move to professor anger thereafter
okay so i mean as you point out muhammad
in electronics you can write down
all the equations um they're
i mean you could even even simulate them
with all their ugliness and programs
like spice
but
again the one thing that's special here
is that devices the devices themselves
are
have reliable properties predictable
properties i mean they may not be as
they may not be linear i mean you know
diodes are voltage defending capacitors
etc etc but this this works and to the
extent that you have a nervous system
and the components are relatively fixed
uh in time
you you can make good predictions um you
know i brought up the one example the
recent example of the central complex
the heading sensor and the fly
if we roll back uh
almost 40 years ago i mean there was
beautiful work on small systems
uh in tritonia in um
in the in the in the in the gastric mill
in the stomach of the lobster and um
even allowing for things like modulators
as long as the levels stay constant
people
were able to make good models of the
circuits but i i just want to harp back
again a little to the issue that the
components are plastic and this is
something that's just beginning to come
into the electronics world
in like so-called memory devices or
memory resistors
but um
i i mean i disagree with florian that we
we know enough i i think
uh we don't know enough i think we we
barely understand memory we have an idea
of eligibility traces as a concept to
extend correlations across events in
time
when we take the events one at a time
but but we don't see the world one at a
time we see the world as many events at
a time with so there's many eligibility
traces just to pick up on our theme i
think we're extremely naive about issues
of plasticity and there we need um
experimental guidance i i also just i i
mean not the harp on physics but it
provides good examples
to go back to the
the issue of
magnetism i mean what florian said is is
true coulomb's law of special relativity
allows you to calculate the residual
effect
when you have balancing charges this
gives you magnetism but to understand
magnetic materials you often appeal to
an intermediate level of understanding
so you it's very difficult often to
calculate the detailed interactions
between magnetic centers and a material
but
you know enough about symmetries that
have to be obeyed that you could
put in by hand
an interaction which is physically
reasonable and then calculate all the
way up to say a macroscopic quantity
and i think science uh least physics
chemistry has made progress by putting
in intermediate steps
and then only later justifying them in a
microscopic way as has happened in
superconductivity and magnetism is two
famous examples
um so just um for the sake of the
argument to disagree a bit with florian
who i love dearly
um you um
i mean you i think you they
can you interrupt each other
um you always interrupt me so that's
okay but
no no i'm just wondering whether what's
the format here whether we can turn this
into a discussion or whether you prefer
to have these separate statements
yes you i think so from my perspective i
think a discussion
a discussion back and forth uh you know
is fine by me so
okay
because okay um what david says
is is something that i actually um
i mean i almost agree with right i think
david is absolutely correct that the um
rules of plasticity i think is something
that
should be almost discussed separately
because there's a sort of one question
about
how the brain works in terms of
processing information
the other one is how it works in terms
of
memory and learning and plasticity and
david already in our previous discussion
two days ago and
pointed out that that's where the
analogy falls short
with computers because computers are not
plastic they can't update them on the
fly
and and i think that's that's absolutely
true um i think the only thing where
david and i um
disagree maybe i'm not even sure we
fundamentally disagree but i can
generate an artificial disagreement here
for the sake of discussion where david
thinks that the plasticity rules that we
have discovered so far
are probably not sufficient to explain
the
dynamic plasticity of the brain and i
will for the sake of argument
put forth here that they might be that
the rules of the fifth place physically
that we have discovered in the in the
past which is spike timing dependent
plasticity which is um um reinforcement
kind of specificity that sort of
additional rule of dopamine or serotonin
of neuromodulators that can change
synapses
that
at least in my mind these rules in
principle could suffice
to explain i think all kinds of um
learning and memory in theory yes um
like the eligibility traces that david
mentioned before i think they can just
operate in parallel in a in a complex
neural network like the retrain um where
i actually agree with david is that
it's likely that we are
have fallen short
in describing all the complexity and
plasticity of the vertebrate brain as a
it's probably a very good idea and i'm
totally on board with david to
systematically test um these fundamental
plasticity rules experimentally and find
out whether my somewhat naive assumption
that spike timing the dependent
plasticity and reinforcement
rules might be enough to explain it all
um because most likely if we actually do
these experiments and test what
plasticity rules actually exist at the
cellular level i'll be proven wrong and
david is going to be proven right so
back to you david
i actually want to i want to ask a
follow-up that ties very nicely i think
into this which is
you know there is obviously um some
differences of opinion some of which i
think is fluorine alluded to is
performative because you know scientists
hold nuanced opinions
but but continuing along that strain
there is a difference ostensibly because
um
or perhaps there's a difference because
of some experiments that have not yet
been run
or an inability to collect let's say a
certain kind of data that would allow
you to
get rid of a hypothesis either prove it
correct or incorrect and so on
i'd love to hear from both professor
kleinfeld as well as
professor engert about what are
what are those experiments what kind of
tools would be necessary to help get to
an authoritative answer to close out
this debate and
are those on the horizon those kinds of
experiments so i'd love to maybe we
could start again with professor
kleinfeld and then move to professor
enger
yeah so um
you know i'm
even though what we're doing very now is
really sort of macroscopic systems
neuroscience i
i really think that the field could take
a shift back to a reductionist view and
and particularly so
when it comes to issues of plasticity
and let me just give two examples
where cell culture was key i mean one of
course is spike time independent
plasticity this was uh our colleague
chung b's work with with moving poo
this is a culture experiment
there's always arguments oh it's in
culture it's not the same as in the
animal but to establish fundamental
principles i think the ability to go
into the dish the ability to
resolve individual synapses now you know
you could to image at quarter micron
resolution just
push the technology some of which came
out of the brain program
is the way to be and another famous
story that came out of the dish
is our scaling laws this is uh alex
ray's experiment
uh it was to me was sort of a shocking
finding uh there was a
a theory about balance uh between
inhibition and excitation uh uh current
into a cell so the
the mean is close to zero but the cell
is very noisy because the variance is
adding
and in order for this to happen you
needed a kind of scaling with synaptic
density that went like the square root
of the density i mean this and
they alex found something very close so
i mean to push this further and
understand is it
spiking in the postsynaptic cell or is
it just depolarization or what the
molecular events are as as a few people
in the world are doing beautifully
i i think this needs to get pushed i
think we need a very reductionist view
towards pushing to a synaptic physiology
and um
the flip side is um there are good tools
now to look at individual synapses
within the same cell
you know i'm thinking of
glutamate dyes
calcium
calcium dyes that are localized to a
synapse we could get an idea of what the
correlation lengths are in individual
cells it means people still fight about
this or is the spine isolated is the
spine not isolated how far apart are
synapses that influence each other i i
think i i view these as basic questions
and um
i think the technology is pushing there
and you know again i'll make a plug for
the brain program the
ability to to
to to push all these technologies die
makers and physiologists
and optics jocks uh in the same
direction has
has has been great and it's still
growing i mean there's no end in sight
so i think there's basic experiments
looking at the microscopic level both in
the animal and in the dish
so florian what do you think
i think that's great i think i'm all for
the developing of technology because i
think even if i
don't necessarily agree that we might
that we need these um experiments say at
the single spine level whether the spine
is isolated or not
i don't think we actually need them to
understand the brain at the microscopic
level i think that's sort of a question
here
nonetheless if you do the kind of
experiments that david just suggested
you make inevitably important
fundamental discoveries about basics
that will help you understand the basic
biology of the brain i think this is
always useful
my
hope even or my
suspicion is that these details
don't really matter all that much in
terms of understanding the complexity of
circuits and behavior
so i think the experiment that mohammed
was
referring to that i would like to do to
prove my point right namely that we
don't need a further theory is that if
we just take the principles that that we
have in hand right now about synapses
about excitation and
inhibition modulation
about the basic rule of of plasticity
that we have in hand
and if we start
putting all of these elements together
in a small and simple brain like in my
case for example the larval zebrafish
the larval zebrafish has a hundred
thousand neurons and i think in
principle it's possible now to um to
model the whole zebrafish brain
my prediction is once we have
the
data at sufficient resolution i think
what we need in this case is basically a
connectome and the um
an insight about the
connectivity the synapses
that exist once we once we put all of
these existing principles together
into a
[Music]
brain like the larval zebrafish's brain
can we run it and generate the output of
a lot of zebrafish so can we basically
simulate a simple organism like that
with all the
elements that we have in place already
if that works i would argue then it
tells us that we don't need to add any
more details or fundamental theory to
understand the at least the vicious
brain
and
and i think the other experiment the
fundamental experiment i would add is to
start putting together the sub-circuits
that elicit the individual behaviors of
a lot of zebra fish like hunting like
escape like rio taxis optimoto response
and if we can
stimulate so in in a computer recreate
these neural networks run them and then
generate um
an animal in vitro that is
indistinguishable from a live animal i
think that's an experiment that sort of
tells you that our theoretical framework
is sufficient i think that's sort of the
experiment i'd like to do
to show that we have all the fundamental
tools already in hand to explain at
least the um
tiny vertebrate brain or any brain and
then i would argue that the rest going
from a larval zebrafish to a juvenile to
a mouse to a monkey to a human is just a
matter of um
of expanding right it's not a
fundamental new thing we need it's just
a way of slowly and deliberately and
expanding um our knowledge and um
and the complexity
that's so yeah how hard
so
foreign yes
so the the thing is is that if there's a
behavior that's a that's a zebrafish
does that is that it's quite plastic at
learning quickly like
just
in one of your fish tanks um
gain control right they do motor
learning they do very quick motor
learning gain adaptation
okay so why
but um
but that has periods of learning and
periods of stability where it's not
learning
and um
so how do you i mean it always seemed uh
interesting to me and i would say
unresolved to know when do you
when are you actually learning and when
do you uh have stable stable output and
you can't say oh there's a modulator
because that's a chicken and egg problem
how do you maintain no no no no
so i see that as fundamental
and i see that as a fundamental floor in
our theoretical understanding of nervous
systems
is the uh
ability to
pick pick a certain level of stability
so we get up in the morning we're the
same person but yet we could learn in
single trial learning i mean it seems
miraculous
but it's miraculous because we really
have no theoretical clues unless i'm
missing something
yeah maybe yeah maybe i i don't know i
think
it could be that it's a question of um
of sensitizing a system
such that it it's plastic and like a a
boost of adrenaline
it can be elicited by a mismatched
signal from
an error signal that comes from the
world that can generate a neuromodulator
that suddenly induces a brief transient
period of plasticity
and if that mismatch arrow signal that
can either come as an unconditioned cue
from the outside world or it can be a
mismatch signal between a reafferent
stimulus and apparent copy that that
induces brief periods of plasticity
or like a surprise signal from dopamine
right you have a an error prediction
signal or a climbing fiber signal right
from the inferior olives into the
cerebellum there's a teaching and error
signal
that will induce brief periods of
plasticity and of course the question is
what induces these
brief periods of plasticity but this can
either be an external cube yes and that
makes the current context more relevant
to the animal so there's no mystery
there there's no fatal misunderstanding
or it could be a mismatch signal between
your reference copy and like a forward
model that gets generated by the brain
and the afferent signal it comes back
and if there's a large enough mismatch
then you open a brief window for
learning in plasticity how about that
david
well uh you know it sounds good but i
think there's some flaws i mean a
climbing fiber signal goes to a specific
cell it's an instructional signal that
goes to
one purkinje cell
and um
and
maybe
one could argue that there's some
reasonable understanding of the
cerebellum at least in within its own
within its own right with its own closed
loop but a dopamine signal goes
everywhere and it's yeah and i'm not
even sure people are even looking in the
right place for for things like
correlations you know they they like the
strategy because
yeah so i don't agree i think that
people might not be looking at the right
place but i don't think we are lacking a
fundamental theory i think the theory is
there it's just a question of getting
people to look in the right place i
agree with that
um okay you're a little
i think you're playing devil's advocate
here i mean i take reinforcement theory
to a point but it it's really uh only
considering sort of single learning
exercises at a time it's not trying to
learn you know multiple you're not
following multiple inputs with with
multiple solutions like you do during
the day you walk around your lab and you
yeah you know yell at every postdoc and
students individually
but doesn't that that's poverty of
experimental design or the quality of
the experimental design we are not
asking a mouse to learn or wrap to learn
many things in parallel we are actually
deliberately constraining our
experiments to our one time and i think
that's the
i think we've asked you hello
yeah and we're here
yes yes so i think that's it
hello dr ringer we lost you again
yes we can hear you please go ahead
oh can you hear me no
yeah yeah yeah off and on okay sorry i
think i i've got my my phone too close
to the ear it presses zero accidentally
anyway i think david's right but i think
that the issue is that we design our
experiments such that an animal needs to
learn one thing at a time like a mouse
in a in a classic reinforcement learning
experiment or even a monkey so we are
not designing our experiments to ask
whether animals can learn many things in
parallel and i think if we did that we
would actually we could redesign
experiment to ask exactly these
questions about multiple electric
eligibility traces and and parallel
learning in a in a rapidly changing
world so i think it's not a problem
again of a lack of theory it's a lack of
i wouldn't even say poor experimental
design i think simplifying things um
when you want to study them is often
useful and off for especially in physics
and probably in neuroscience we've been
one that we have wandered off the the
beaten track in particular um
with respect to reinforcement learning
in mammals and rodents where we um ask
probably mice and rats
to solve the wrong tasks and maybe
that's the problem right now why we
making we can't really make a lot of
progress with parallel learning and like
dopamine reinforcement learning is
because we are not really asking the
mouse the correct question what do you
think david
i i mean i i agree i mean i we you know
we could
and we would go ahead and do different
experiments maybe um i just
again i would just take a more
reductionist approach but i'm also
even at this high level i'm i'm just
very nervous about what we learn there's
there seems to be a lot of group think
in in the area that studies plasticity
the most which is sort of the
reinforcement dopamine world hopefully
i'm not offending anybody but
one takes one
one takes risks um
but
it doesn't there's a lot of things that
as you point out see my contradictions
the place where the information is the
densest which is cortex or even
hippocampus is not where we're looking
uh for the plastic
yeah i agree i completely agree with
that i think that
there is a lot of improvement i think um
possible for just
experimental designs and also how you
ask the right question i agree with that
i don't think
that we are actually lacking um a
fundamental understanding or um or a
theory how it could work and maybe um i
should also um
say something about um sort of a
dichotomy between
understanding i think there is a lack of
like a ignorance or a lack of
understanding where we have no idea how
it could possibly work like if you watch
a stage magician it's just a mystery and
we have no idea
and another form of ignorance is where
we have many ideas how it could work we
just don't know whether the model we
have our intuition is actually correct
or not that's a different form of
ignorance in my opinion about
neuroscience and brain science it's it's
that we are more struggling with the
latter that we can
come up with ways how it could all work
and it all makes sense we just don't
know whether we are actually um on the
right track i think but that's a similar
that's a different form of ignorance
it's not the ignorance where we just
puzzled and we are clearly lacking a
theory whereas it's one where we just
need to look more carefully and convince
ourselves which of our several intuitive
models is actually the correct one
over
okay so i think this is maybe the the uh
at least for the sake of this
public debate this is
where we park company a little bit i
think we're missing some fundamental
experimental key like looking at the
musician from behind the stage or
something let's see what that's true
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and okay again i i should really
agree with david here is that i think
these experiments that david is asking
for i'm also for them i think they will
um
reveal
new insights that are fundamental and
they are fundamental at the detailed
molecular
and
mechanistic level and i think they're
going to be immensely useful yeah
my only i think maybe the only way we
disagree i don't think that they are
going to be absolutely critical for us
to understand the brain at a at a new
and different level
over
okay
if if if i may just for the purposes of
allowing us to get to the audience
interaction section here
i'd like to i'd like to pivot um the
conversation
uh to to questions that are being posed
by members of the audience and
i know that some of the other members
from the nih team
had been keeping an eye on on some of
the questions and highlighted those for
me so if you give me a moment i'm gonna
hold those up on my end
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna start we're
gonna switch now very quickly to the the
audience portion of this discussion
and i'm going to open up with asking the
first one here which is might be
possible to have
local theories
at different scales of understanding
that's the opening
from the audience
okay i mean um
for him i'll just sort of mention this i
mean i
um
again i mean physics does provide uh
a very uh nice use of this i mean we're
we're almost all used to this
i mean we don't we don't we don't think
about quarks we think of of nuclei and
then if we're um
doing chemistry
uh we don't even think about the whole
atom we just think about the valence
electrons in the atom
so
if you're if you're trying to go from
atoms to molecules it's just valence
electrons if you're
trying to build materials you start to
think about the molecules
as a whole and then that's a whole
nother simplicity you don't
um
even have to think about details of
quantum mechanics you just think about
what
is the square of the wave function just
the electron density same as functional
density theory so it i think with again
appealing to physics and chemistry as
sort of successful science for the
design of structures
um
it's it's usually hard enough to can
just connect two levels
and so you do this in neuroscience of
course you don't think about channel
kinetics you you really think about
neurons spiking and you don't even think
about the details of the spike you just
know that there's a probability for
synaptic release say and you know that
there's a probability that
cells will fire and you could read them
out so we're we're
on that level we're very good at
connecting but i mean i would bring up
just one point here before giving this
to florian which was a comment that my
colleague uh florian's colleague uh
jaime samplinski brought up is that the
challenge of the brain is that
on while on this uh sort of hardware
level
you have these intermediate steps from
the point of connectivity
you have connections on all possible
scales and that's what makes it uh
difficult this and this segways into
florian's previous comments about the
connectome
so
for it what do you what do you think
about this
well i i guess the question again was
whether we could have theories at
different levels is this right muhammad
yeah
yeah
okay so i think that
our theory of the of the neurobiology of
neurons is actually almost
rather complete and relatively speaking
i think we have a very good idea how
um how neurons work how receptors work
how channels work i mean and how the
potassium channel opens we know that i
think we know how synaptic vesicle
release works to extraordinarily
um
satisfactory levels i don't think that
we are actually lacking a a
theoretical understanding at that
molecular level at the synaptic and at
the neuronal level um
so um
i think it's more the question
um
that we are struggling with that is how
this vast dynamical system this emerging
dynamic system of a
hundred thousand or a million or a
billion neurons that interact and how
that gives rise to
behavior and thought and so i i'm not
sure that the theory at the molecular
level is lacking or would help us that
much um but i don't know it might
actually again i have to say this again
and again i'm i'm just speculating i'm
i'm not talking from
a position of certainty in any way i'm
just um i just try to keep this debate
lively so
to answer the the
question from the audience i don't think
that um
we are actually lacking um a theory at
the mechanistic neuronal level i think
the the challenge really is just to
apply this um
these principles that we know already um
to the level and scale
of neuron and synapses at the at the
magnitude of a vertebrate plane
oh well
that's actually a good transition into
one of the questions that was related to
this again from the audience which i'll
read out
so
remember the audience asks maybe we can
phrase the question a little differently
a theory should allow accurate
predictions
can the complex non-linearities have
multiple
inter
digitating time scales of the brain be
simplified into more simple equations
that can make interesting accurate
predictions
what level of accuracy would we desire
and what do we want to predict
oh yeah can i take that
absolutely please please
go ahead and
i think that the brain is fundamentally
a stochastic addiction machine not a
an accurate deterministic
dynamical system so um
accurate predictions i think are
impossible and what the only thing we
can hope for are stochastic predictions
and i think that's fundamentally the
reason for that is that the neuronal
processes at the fundamental level after
hashtag in nature and not deterministic
i think the
other problem with the
goal of making
predictions generally how a brain will
behave
dr ingrid i think we lost you
oh he lost both of us
oh
can you all hear me okay
uh i hear you um
yeah i hear you and i don't uh somehow
the video is dead uh
but that's okay
yeah i think that's fine i mean it seems
that um
dr engert has we've lost him from now so
maybe um dr kleinfeld if you want to
we'd love to hear your take on it as
well
um
you know
on
the question with what precision you
could define um
what's the precision that makes a theory
valid right i'll i'll go ahead and
repeat it so that the the the just the
you know sort of the core of the
question was can the complex
non-linearities add multiple time scales
of the brain be simplified
into you know more consolidated
equations
that can help make accurate predictions
and then if if that's true what level of
accuracy do we need and what we want to
predict with that
okay so at one level you could say the
bottom line is is really predicting
motor output
and and what's the chunking in time you
need to predict
uh
motor output so we have a little bit of
a clue from that even from industry for
vector quantization say of
a voice which is one great motor output
and we're really
chopping boys at something that
approximates about 10 hertz into
intervals
so
i think you could say that if you
for a theory that enables us to comp
to
compute how we can communicate
you could you could chop time i think we
always have we have to appeal to um
really issues of motor output
and um
i mean i i don't know i i just i feel
you can't really make an absolute uh
judgment here i mean that's
theoretical neuroscience is pretty crude
right now
um i could go back to this example again
of the
central complex
um you look at the data you you're
measuring neuropill and there's a blob
and the blob is shaking around
and just computing the average activity
of that blob
basically one the centroid
of a blob moving on a circle and leaves
the queer victory and and i agree you
could declare victory but um
someone else could say well but you're
not really capturing the jittering of
the fly as it moves towards a landmark
so i i would say
it's just an opinion completely that you
know just to get one decimal place
in and getting the average motion
uh in calculating the output from an
animal is very impressive today i i
would declare victory i would give
tenure to anybody who does that
awesome
okay so
yeah i don't know if dr engert is back
but if you are we'd like to give you an
opportunity to finish your
thoughts yeah no i'm back sorry about
that um
no i i think actually i'm not sure i
didn't say hear what david said at the
beginning but um
i heard something about motor output is
key and i completely agree with that i
think that's the purpose ultimately of
the brain is to generate adaptive motor
output and ultimately um that is i think
what needs predicting
um
of course i think it's not just the in
the mid individual motor movement of of
any animal what one has to predict is um
the motor output at many many different
spatial and behavioral and temporal
scales right so if one can do that
is
predict sort the gist of the motor the
adaptive motor output then then i i
agree with david then we can declare
victory so the stochastic behavior of
the animal that makes um adaptive sense
if we can generate that predict that or
simulate that then i think
yes victory can be declared and again i
think one way of generating these
predictions is not just with um with
algorithms um on paper i think the way
we can predict is by running a network
that's a term i learned from david right
if you you generate a network you
hypothesize what it looks like and then
you run it in a computer and you add the
actuators the muscles and you have an
animal that actually behaves in a
virtual world i think that is to me
the best um prediction that one can
generate and that we can compare now
with the reality at the stochastic level
over
so
yeah i agree i i seem to remember
discussing this about three years ago in
washington back when people actually
took jet planes uh to go to meetings
um
you know there but
i mean the problem is uh particularly as
a theorist you get greedy
and you don't want just a computer
output that tends to match you'd like to
in a perfect world
get something simplified some equations
that talk to you that maybe give you the
voice give you the motion
in ways you could see some
simplification
um yeah just like
um trying to
but that's the question right i think do
these do these exist these
simplifications do they exist or are we
chasing a ghost here right is the um is
the ultimate answer is it just gonna be
a complex network that we can run and
that will generate the same um
outputs and that is just really
complicated i mean it's a little bit
like the theory of itself right i don't
think you have a a simplified theory of
how a cell works yeah
um but i don't think we are lacking it
either what do you say what do you think
david no i i agree with you you have
many processes in parallel with similar
importance
and you just can't
you can't knock it down to
some yeah it doesn't compress anymore
yeah there's no no principal component
that describes it all or a simplified
equation like the maxwell equations
right or the navier-stokes equation and
i don't think that exists for the brain
well i i i don't know but i i i just i
i'd be skeptical
yeah okay so i'm i'm hopeful but
good
no this is this is wonderful so uh what
i what i want to do is ask one more
question from the audience to wrap up
and then we'll wrap up the discussion
for the for the afternoon
so the last question
is won't any general theory of learning
for example outside the context of the
innate drives to preferentially learn
certain motor actions inherently take us
down the wrong road
in other words should the brain
initiative be more comparative
can you repeat that please
wait no no can you repeat that
absolutely so i'll repeat the question
the question is won't any general theory
of learning for example
outside the context of the innate drives
to preferentially learn certain motor
actions
inherently take us down the wrong road
in other words should the brain
initiative be more comparative
okay like
comparative you mean uh just understand
comparative
comparative in terms of learning
paradigms or comparative in terms of
of animal
animals
i i believe uh the context here is in
animals based on based on the
the person who submitted the question
yeah i mean that's
that's a great point i mean when i
you know there was a time when people
would say
you choose the animal
to solve the problem that's most
interesting if it's in a if it's a if
it's a speech issue you choose a
songbird if it's a manipulation issue
maybe
it's it's a new world monkey if it's an
auditory issue it's it's an it's it's an
owl etc etc you really try to pick the
right species and we we've gone away
from that and and we've we've gone into
you know
uh mice and and uh drosophila and uh
and zebrafish and uh maybe i'm missing
something um
and i think the worm yeah sorry
another group another group that i've
managed to anger today um
but
you know the worm has
has this great capabilities in terms of
molecular tools and the speed with which
you could access things but i
i really believe in the comparative
approach i mean this gets banged into me
all the time by my colleague harvey
carton you just it these are nervous
systems these these are in principle
whatever
the circuit is that's developed in one
animal that that circuit or an analogous
circuit could develop in in a different
animal it's all giving us clues about
the nervous system i think we're pretty
um
i think we have to be honest with
ourselves we're neuroscience is is
fascinating obviously florian you
um everybody at the nih we we've devoted
our lives to it but it's a pretty crude
subject at some level
and and the more breadth of
experimentation we do and the more we
could explain with our models the more
progress we'll make
so i i would uh you know i personally
even though we're not doing this per se
at the moment i i put a big plug in for
the comparative approach
orion what do you what do you say
now completely agree i i don't really
understand the dichotomy in the question
i don't think there's actually either
either we have a general learning
model or we take the comparative
approach i think we sort of can do
both no i i don't also know what the
general learning model
the learning theory what that really
means i think that there is sort of a
fundamental concept in learning like
reinforcement learning or classical
conditioning or sort of um yeah i i
don't know associative learning um and i
think
that's a good idea yes to try to
conceptualize how learning works to to
to think about um
innate drives about reinforces to think
about how memories get written how they
get stored stably for a long time how
they get recalled i think all of this
requires a sort of conceptual framework
but i think the way you apply it and
test it is by looking as many different
animals as you can like what david said
right if you want to do inter-oral time
different comparison you look in barn
owls and um if you if you yeah songbird
learning is zebra finches and so forth
so i think that
this is not um an either or i think
having a conceptual theories about
learning how it should work is useful is
almost required um
but in order to apply it i think one one
almost has to go to a
comparative approach because um that's
how you learn about general principles
right you can't just study a mouse or
just a lot of zebra fish
you have to if you if you think you um
you understand how something works you
have to test it in a in a broad range of
of contexts of conditions and therefore
in different species
over
i
think
well go ahead
no i'd say we i think we agree at last
okay awesome well that's a wonderful
note then for me to say that uh we're
going to go ahead and and wrap up the
debate we've gone for the full
uh the full hour period i want to end
this debate by saying
i really i want to offer the profound
gratitude of you know not only myself
but my colleagues at the national
institutes of health
and uh the broader community for
dr engert and dr kleinfeld your
willingness to participate in this and
to to do this as a dialogue and to talk
about
areas where there's differences i think
it's a wonderful stimulating thing
especially for junior scientists
to help them think about what some of
the next steps uh might be to push the
field forward i certainly learned a lot
i'm sure others have as well so thank
you both so much for your willingness to
do this
thank you so much yeah no no thank you
and not just for allowing us to discuss
but also for reconnecting david and
myself i i've been i've sorely missed
talking to david and discussing
science with him and this just gave me a
really wonderful opportunity
this was awesome
yeah thank you also you know i always
enjoy chatting with florian we did the
imaging course
together many years ago and i have to
say this venue was much safer because
one day florian said let's swim from
banbury to cold spring harbor and timed
it perfectly as the tide was going out
and
we survived
we
survived
wonderful
i i for one feel i for one feel very
optimistic that between um
sharp minds that have engaged in this
debate as well several of the others we
heard from
uh earlier today i think whatever the
answer is someone who's been on a call
or given a presentation today will help
us get to the answer the bottom of it so
thank you both again for your time
okay thank you
okay over and out thank you everyone and
greetings to the audience yeah
thanks
for your participation
okay bye-bye muhammad thanks so much for
inviting us and
okay thank you jim and and karen and
christina okay and
susan okay thank you bye